[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم حين طلب من الملك تشارلز الامير
انذاك ان يكون راعيا لمركز يوكسفورد
للدراسات الاسلاميه اصر ان يكون المبنى من
تصميم ضيفنا في هاتين الحلقتين المعماري
المصري المهندس عبد الواحد الوكيل في
اشاره الى تفرده وتميزه اللافت في العماره
الاسلاميه ولد الوكيل في حي جاردن سيتي في
القاهره عام
1943 ونشا في بيت عمته زوجه مصطفى النحاس
باشا درس في كليه فيكتوريا ومدارس
انجليزيه اخرى ثم تحصل على شهاده
البكالوريوس في العماره بدرجه الامتياز مع
مرتبه الشرف وعمل معيدا في الجامعه من عام
65 حتى العام 1970 لم ترق له المدارس
السائده في صفوف النخبه المعماريه
الجامعيه في تلكم الفتره والتي تاثر
معظمها بالعماره الغربيه الحديثه قدم
استقالته بعد ان تعرف على المعماري
المنبوذ من تلك الاوساط الجامعيه
حسن فتحي وذهب الاثنان في مشواري اعاده
اكتشاف العماره الاصيله وطرق البناء
والمواد المستخدمه ثمه ما يعارض الجديد
القادم والمكلف وغير المتناسق مع هويه
البلاد ومتطلبات اهلها خاض الوكيل مشواره
المعماري على غير ما بدا وقع غرامه في
المساجد يرى فيها التعبير الامثل والاجمل
عن روح العماره الاسلاميه ليس شكلا فقط بل
هويه ومعنى وقدته مسيرته الى معقل المساجد
وقبلتها الاساسيه من بيروت انتقل الى
السعوديه وصمم هناك مسجد قباء ومسجد
القبلتين في المدينه المنوره ومسجد الملك
سعود ومسجد الجزيره في جده وقصر سليمان
الذي نال عليه جائزه لم تكن الوحيده في
مسيرته المعماريه فقد حاز عبد الواحد
الوكيل على جائزه الاغاخان للعماره عن
تصميمه لبيت حلاوه بالاسكندريه عام 80 ثم
جائزه الملك فهد للبحوث في العماره
الاسلام
وجائزه الزمان الفخريه من قبل المعهد
الامريكي للمهندسين المعماريين وصولا الى
جائزه ريتشارد لاسهاماته في الهندسه
المعماريه الكلاسيكيه عام 2008 وجائزه دره
هاوس للاماره الكلاسيكيه من جامعه نوتردام
الامريكيه وقد شغل الوكيل عضويه مجلس
امناء التراث العالمي والمجلس الاكاديمي
لمدرسه امير ويلز للهندسه المعماريه ولجنه
التحكيم لجائزه الاغاخان للعماره المهندس
المعماري المصري البارز عبد الواحد الوكيل
ضيف المقابله في حلقتين فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
المعماري الكبير المش مهندس عبد الواحد
الوكيل انا سعيد جدا بوجودك في المقابله
بعدين انا اخذتك للطبيعه انا اعرف انه
عندك حساسيه من العماره فاخذتك لمكان
محايتك الطبيعه كما هي نعود للبدايات من
مواليد الاربعين في اي سنه ولدت
والاسره اسره
لها مكانتها اسره بشوات خلينا نقول
كيف يعني
ذكرني في البيئه اللي ولدت فيها الحياه
اللي عشتها في طفولتك الاولى اول شيء
والله احنا عشنا في الفتره
كانت
يعني
ببعتونا مدارس
كان دايما يعني يقول لك اللي ينجح في
حياته العمليه لازم يخش المدارس انجليزي
كان عندنا احسن مدرسه فيكتوريا كان بيجيها
كل اللي بقوا بعد كده في السعوديه وفي
الكويت وفي الكويت والعراق كلهم كانوا
موجودين عندنا
الاولاد الاغنياء والحكام الحكام كانت
فيكتوريا في مصر وفي اسكندريه والانجلش
سكول في
فيليوبلس مصر الجديده
فمريت على التلاته انا تعليم انجليزي
كيف اثرت على شخصيتك في البدايه لانه
بعدين يعني ما قالت اليه الامور مختلفه
تماما والله
انا كنت في الداخليه ابويا وامي انفصلوا
وبعدين ما كنتش مبسوط في في المدرسه
فخدتني يا عمتي عشان ما يبقاش في حوار بين
ابويا وامي مين اللي ياخد عمتك زوجه مصطفى
النحاسبك
فتربيت معاها
ودي خلتني يعني لما تخرج عايز اعمل حاجه
اخدم فيها البلد
[موسيقى]
فلقيت حسن فتحي قبل حسن فتحي اللي ابن
اسره بشوات في مدارس انجليزيه في في اجواء
مثل هذه الاجواء المفروض انه علاقته
بالثقافه العربيه والاسلاميه ضعيفه جدا
جدا المفروض اللي صار معك العكس
بعدين انا انا مره عتبت ابويا وقلت له
يعني احنا عندنا في مدارس كان يمنعونا
نتكلم انجليزي كان المفروض تبعتني كتاب
زعل مني قال لي احسن مدارس دلوقتي بتانبني
بس الكتاب تعليم اللغه القران واللغه
العربيه والاشياء المهمه وبعدين انا تعرفت
على الشيخ الخطاطين الله يرحمه محمد عبد
القادر
وابتديت اتعلم الخط العربي معاه وبعدين اه
لبعد ما تخرجت لما ابتديت تعمل المساجد
يعني انا برده حبيت اعمل مساجد حتى ارجع
للعماره الاسلاميه وانت تدرس في فيكتوريا
وفي المدارس الانجليزيه كنت مزعوج
ولا كنت مبسوط لا لقت مدارس تحفه تحفه
انه الواحد يعني شعب مصري طفل مصري يريد
ان يتعلم لغته العربيه تاريخه وثقافه هذه
ما كانت موجوده في المدرس ايوه بس احنا
كاطفال ما نعرفش يعني امتى الثوره صارت في
وقطعت مع البشاويه مع الاقطاعيين مع
الملاك كان عمرك 11 سنه تقريبا
صدمت فيها تاثرت فيها لا والله قعدنا
قعدنا سنتين بره لما حصلت الثوره ودخلت
مدرسه في سويسرا
سنتين وبعدين ما كناش عارفين حيصلي بس كنت
شاعر انه اللي حصل في الستينة وخمسين ضدكم
كطبقه كفئه واللي حصل عندنا زي ما بيحصل
في كل ثوره كان ادمن برك يقول
ريفلوشن دي
يعني اللي هي
[موسيقى]
بتخرب جيل بحاله
لان التغيير
المفاجئ بياثر على المجتمع
باساليب سلبيه جامده ايش اكبر تاثير عليك
من تلك المرحله يعني من 43 52 كانت حياه
وخمسين صار في تغيير كبير
وقابلت راجل عظيم يمكن تعرفهم من المغرب
ونحن بنبني محاضره في الجامعه الاسلاميه
في تركيا
طه عبد الرحمن اهم فيلسوف
اديت محاضره عن العماره فقام حضني قال لي
انا بشد شعري على اللي بيحصل في المدن
العربيه
وانت يعني شرحت قلبي باللي بتقوله
وبدات صداقه معه
فاكتشفت ان هو كمان كان شاعر وان 67 عملت
له صدمه ساب الشاعر وداخل في المنطق
والفلسفه والفلسفه انا لما تعرفت عليك
مهندس عبد الواحد وقرات لم اتخيل انه هذا
المعماري المؤمن بثقافه الثقافه الاسلاميه
والتاريخ والعماره الاسلاميه يكون بهذه
الجدر يعني تعليم انجليزي تعليم غربي
فيكتوريا فكان شيء غريب بالنسبه لي واضح
انه في صدمه صح مش غريب لان هو لو تاخد
مثلك
كان يفترض الطبيعي انه يكون على ستايل
الغربي المدرسه ابن المدرسه الغربيه ولا
لا صح شو
اللي حصل في التاريخ موجود وفي كاتب كان
بيقول مثلا واحد زي هتلر واحد زي
جاب كم شخصيه يقول لك دول
كانوا بره بلدهم حتى يعرفوا
اللي بيحصل في بلده يعني كان نظر من
الخارج
لانك انت لما تكون انا حتى كنت اتعلمت مع
طلياني كان عندي هوايه الرسم وانا شاب
ورسمت بورتريه لابويا فكان في واحد اسمه
سيليو تيتالياني كان ابوه جاء انتونينه بك
ده يدرس لليله المالكه الملكات
وهو فتح مدرسه فلما لقوا الموهبه فيا كنت
اروح له في اسكندريه وكان كل صفيه تلات
اشهر اقعد اروح المدرسه بدل ما العب مع
اولاد عمته بتاعي يروح يشتغل ارسم اتعلم
الرسم
حبيت الرسم
وابتديت الرسمه
بالعماره
النهضه
وحتى البيت عمتي كان معمول من احلى بيوت
هو هو
بيت اللي جنبيه كان بتاع فؤاد باشا سراج
الدين كلهم معمولين مهندسين اجانب اعملوها
بالطريقه الاوروبيه
فتربيت في الكلاسيك
فاساسا ما حبتش المدن اللي كان بيدرسونا
لان الكلاسيك فيه رقيه
المشكله ان انت النهارده حتى ما تشكور
في قوانين في رفري يديلك يدي لك كورنر يدي
لك
كارت اصفر
فحتى الجيمز لها قوانين العماره لها
قوانين
العماره الحديثه ملهاش قوانين انا حاجي
للعماره بس عاوز استكمل مسيرتك امتى خرجت
من الثانويه انت روح درست سنتين في سويسرا
خلص سنه وسنه ستين ستين ودخل جامعه لغايه
65 الجامعه دخلت عماره هندسه ليش اخترت
الهندسه والله لان كنت برسم فحسيت انه انت
خلاص صار فيك
الفنان الطلياني قال لي ما تشتغلش فنان
يعني
خليها هوايه عندك ما توكلها ايش لا مش
متوكل ايش يعني
ليست مهنه او تخصص او حتى عشان يعمل فلوس
كان يعمل
عيد الثوره كان يعمل
ديكور كان يعمل
بتاع مسرح يعني كم واحد هيعمل
شمس كانت مزدهره دراسه الهندسه المعماريه
في تلك الفتره والله كانت عين شمس من احسن
كليات
كان فيها طقم مهندسين
يعني دقه قديمه كانوا يعني عندهم مكاتب
وبيبنوا فاهمين دلوقتي الاساتذه اللي في
الجامعه
بتوع كلام لا عمرهم يبنوا ولا في اثر
65 تفوقت
مرتبه الشرف اولى اه طلعت وعينوني مواويل
على الدخان الاول على الدفعه في 65 من 65
ل 70 معيد
من وانا 13 سنه كنت رسمت لابويا وبعتوني
موهبه فيها بعتوني عند الطبع ان ده فتعلمت
حاجات كتيره قبل ما اخش العماره طيب ايضا
اصبحت معيد في الهندسه المعماريه
حسيت بشيء يعني حسيت انه عندك خط معين
هويه معينه ولا لسه طالب فقط لا ابتديت
اعمل الابحاث فحبيت اشوف مش عاجبني اللي
بيحصل في مصر ايش اللي كان يحصل في مصر
والاسكان
اللي عملوه ده خدوه من المانيا اللي هي
سلم وشقتنا كل ناحيه اربع ادوار
ومحطوطين مبسوطين كده ما فيش الروح بتاعه
البلد القديمه البلد القديمه حبيتها ما
كناش نروح يعني اللي هي احياء الشعبيه بس
لما كنت اروح مع استاذ الفنان روح نرسم
الحاجات القديمه
فبتقدر تشوف الجمال في العماره اللي محدش
كلمني عنها في الجامعه
فروحت بقى ادرس للتربه وكلم على العماره
الاسلامي وبعدين دورت مين عنده عماره
اسلامي مين بيعمل شغل ده
وقعت على حسن بس عرفوا ان انا حسن فتحي
قال ابو علي مين حسن فتحي
مواليد 1900
وانت تعرفت عليه تقريبا 68 ولا 70 ولا بعد
سبعين 67 بالضبط 67
سنه ايش كان يعمل
بقيت امشي في الشارع ببكي
فلازم اعمل حاجه للبلد ايه حامل هشيل سلاح
عندنا جيش اكتر من اسرائيل كلها فقلت لازم
اشوف اخدم بلدي ازاي قالوا لي في غيرك
اشطر منك حسن فتحي ده هو يعني خبيره عايز
ايه يعمل الاستيطان
الريفه لان دلوقتي انت تعرف المايجريشن
الهجره على اوروبا وبيغرقوا في الميه
بتاعه كان عندنا هجره في
من الريف المدينه للمدينه فهو قال لك ذكي
جدا قال لك لو احل مشكله الريس مش هتيجي
لان انا عايش في انجلترا في الريف واخد
القطره اوصل 50 دقيقه
بس عايش حياه حلوه ومريحه في في
شوبينج مول في دكاتره في كل حاجه
البشمهندس حسن فتحي كان المهندس معماري
خريج يعني اول اول دفعه اتخرجت همم من
جامعه عين شمس لا كانت
مهندس خانه القاهره
كان بارز في مصر مشهور
لا ما كان معروف ايش اللي وقعك عليه
يعني كيف طحت على حسن فتحي وليش حب لانه
سبب لك مشاكل صح لما جيت تعمل رساله
ماجستير عن حسن فتحي كل اساتذه
هم يقول لك الطينه ده هيرجعنا ورا
الجاموسه لكن لو تبص في التاريخ
الفراعنه تشوف المعابد وتشوف الاهرامات
وبتاع لكن عمرك ما تشوف بيت فرعون اللي هو
بيقول لك ده فرعون ما فيش بيت فرعون لان
بيت فرعون كان بالطينه زيت
[موسيقى]
فهي الفكره
اللي انا يعني اختلفت فيها مع استاذي مش
في العماره بتاع لا من ناحيه السياسيه
انك انت لو عايز تبني للفلاح بالطينه
هيقول لك انا ازاي اجوز بنتي وانا عايش في
بيتنا لان هو عايز يبقى زي المدينه
وقعد الشعب قبلهم انا هخلي كل بيت فلاح
يتبني بالخرسانات المسلح طيب خليني اسالك
سؤال في فرق يعني هل بالامكان بالطينه
خلينا نقول المواد الاوليه الموجوده في
البئر هل بالامكان بناء مباني كبيره فيها
في في التينه في التينه
النيه وفي التينه المحروقه في شيكاغو انا
شفت مبنى 19 دول مبني بالطوب ما صدقتش
اللي هم النطحات السابقات بقى عقوبه كبيره
واختلفت معهم على الموضوع
الطينه لها
يعني زي ما تقول
السوشيال ستيتس بتاعها ان يعني
بتاعه فلاحين بسيطه شعبي بلدي بس كان
فرعون سبته
الجامعه انه وبين مدرسه حسن فتحي وما تريد
هم جايين واخدين دكتوراهات من اوروبا
عاوزين
الكاريكنوم بتاعنا في الجامعه
مؤسسه على
الاجنبي لان بعد ما نتخرج نروح ناخد
دكتوراه بره طيب باشمهندس انا لو فتحت لك
ملف البناء في الخليج والعماره في الخليج
حندخل في مشاكل كثيره حنجيها بعد شويه لما
اخترت انك تروح مع حسن فتحي ايش عملت
رحت معاه
قدمت استقالتي من الكليه من الكوكب
وكانوا عايزين ياذوني
فقدمت استقالتي فرفضوها
فرحت تحت كان في واحد بيحبني في
الاداره يعني عارف انا ابن مين وبتاع وكان
وفدي فقلت له وريني القوانين فلقيت قانون
بيقول ممكن تقدم استقرتك لاسباب عائليه
فقلت له اهو انت بتقول لي ما فيش الاسباب
عائليه قال لي لا دي
للموظفه الحامل اه في النساء قلت له طب ما
قالوش ليه قال عشان اشتراكيه الراجل
فرحت كتبت الاسباب عائليه انا كنت غني
ايضا وقادر على انك انت تعيل نفسك لا لا
قالوا لي لا وابويا كان ضدي وبتاعي
وخدوا كل حاجه هتروح تشتغل فين ما فيش شغل
في البلد
بعد حرب سته وخمسين كانت زي ما حصل بعدين
في 67
قدمت استقاله ورحت يعني بعد استقالتك رحت
اشتغلت مع حسن
في بيته في عنده بيت كان كان ساكن فوق على
السطوح
فكنت اروح اشتغل عنده عملنا له رسومات
عشان يطلع كتابه
الفقراء عماره الفقراء طيب حسن فتحي عن
الاخرين لما تشوف صور قديمه من القاهره
تلاقي السماء كلها اوبب ومنارات المساجد
هي لان في مقامات اه في
التدرجات فهي واخده السما واخده السيلوت
بتاع المدينه
مش مثلا اعلان توشيبا او مراوح مش عارف
ايه او سياره
في التنظيم
يعني انت النهارده عندك انا عندي الرف كتب
احط القران فين في التحتاني وعلى اليمين
ففي
الانسان في في اللي بيسموه التقديس الشيء
تاخذ العماره للفلسفه دائما يعني هذا ما
لاحظته من كثير
ترى العماره كائن حي هي العماره هي
شوف الطفل اول ما بيتولد بيجيبوا له
بلوكات يبني بالليج وبتاع العماره ده
البنى ده هو زي ما تقول اهم للانسان
لان هو
بيخلق
العالم اللي هو عايش فيه انا اريد ان
اتوقف الحيوان وزي الشجر اريد ان اتوقف
هنا وننتقل الى حوارنا على الطاوله اريد
ان استعرض اهم المباني التي انجزتها
والمساجد الكثيره المميزه والجائزه جوائز
التي حصلت عليها ايضا كانت تقديرا لعملك
سعيد جدا بوجود
[موسيقى]
ليست مجرده قطع صناعيه وحسب بل منظومه
متكامله تعبر عن روح الفنان وجوهر ثقافه
مجتمعه وتاريخه ودينه والقيم التي يؤمن
بها تشكل العماره والتخطيط الحضري عالما
تتجسد فيه القيم جميعها للمجتمعات البشريه
ترسم خطوطها انسجاما وتكاملا بين الفكره
المعبر عنها في التصميم والبيئه التي تحيا
فيها هذه الفكره فالانفصال او قطيعه
والاجتهاد خارج هذا التناغم الجميل
والمنشول بين عالم البناء والعماره وعالم
الانسان وما يربطه بمحيطه ومجتمعه
وفي فلك العماره الاسلاميه ثمه محوران
يتجسد الاول في البعد الملموس لها والذي
يتمركز حول جماليه العمران ذاته والادوات
والمواد المستخدمه في انشائه ومدى
انسجامها مع الطبيعه وتناغمها مع المحيط
من خلال استخدام ما هو قادم من الطبيعه
نفسها وتوظيفه بشكل هادئ ومتناغم ومستدعم
ما يجعل من العماره الاسلاميه بطابعها
الجميل وزخارفها المتداخله والتي تعكس
ثقافه محيطها تؤسس لراحه في النظر يتبعها
راحه في النظام القائم على انظمه التهويه
والتدفئه الملائمه لكل فصل من فصول السنه
ولذلك الجانب المعنوي او اللاملموس
المتمحور حول الروحانيه المشبع بها المكان
وما يرضيه من هيبه وخشوع لازم يتملك زائر
المكان ويغوص في اعماقه مت بذلك الوظيفه
الاساسيه والمباشره للعمران في حاجه
الانسان للسكن الى السكينه والطمانينه
وخلق اجواء من التفاعل بين البشر والحجر
تميزت بها على الدوام المدرسه التي انشات
العماره الاسلاميه والتي تضمحل يوما بعد
يوم دون ادراك لاهميتها وجدوها واثرها
العظيم على الفرد والمجتمع والدوله على حد
سواء
المعماري البارز المهندس عبد الواحد
الوكيل نستكمل حوارنا في المقابله سعيد
جدا ان اعيش ايضا هذه الاجواء التي تربط
الاشياء ببعضها يعني ما تقوله دائما ان
العماره وحده عضويه مع البيئه مع الانسان
مع العلاقات وهذا شيء جديد علينا احنا
نتعامل مع العماره على انها شيء منفصل
استكمل مسيرتك انت خلصت اصبحت معيد في
جامعه عين شمس ثم قررت الاستقاله وعملت مع
المعماري حسن فتحي وذهبتم الى الى الى مصر
والى وطبعا كانت الفلسفه التي تجمعك به هي
انه ضد الحداثه ضد التغريب ضد البناء
الجديد الشكل الجديد ضد الحدث احنا يعني
اي اي
حضاره او اي موروث مش ثابت بيتطور يعني ما
فيش حاجه لكن له قواعد الحياه نفسها عباره
عن فيها التغير
خليه الجسم تغير كل سبع سنين الحياه هي
تغيير لازم يكون في تغيير بس التغيير يقبل
للاحسن او للاسوء هم
بيلخبطوا بنت التغيير
والتطور لو حاجه مودرن بيقول انها تطور مش
شرط تكون تطور
يعني
عماره مصر ماذا حدث فيها في السبعينات
خلينا نقول لما كنت مع حسن فتحي كان سيء
جدا
اولا ما كانش في خامات
عملوا اسكان شعبي
على نظام
مشوه الماني اللي هي سلم مع شقتين في اربع
ادوار ما تنفعش معنا يعني خلينا نقول ملمح
البناء الخارجي ملمح البناء الخارجي في
مصر من الستينات للسبعينات ماذا جرى في
ماذا تغير من
منموذج المشوه اللي اتعمل بعد الحرب
العالميه في المانيا وفي فرنسا وفي
انجلترا وبيهدوا كل المباني دي لان فشلت
يعني في كتب طلعت على تاثير المباني على
البني ادم لقوا ان في انجلترا المباني
اللي اتعملت بعد الحرب اولا تنفيذ سيء
وبعدين فيها الجرايم فيها المخدرات فيها
الاعتداء على الجنس في
الاسانسولاتش لكن الانجليزي يحب يكون عنده
صغير بيت صغير هيكون خمسه متر بس يبقى
معاه الجنينه بتاعته ورا ويهتم بالورد
يعني قدام بيته الحديقه الخلفيه وبيعمل
يارد على الشارع دايما يحط فيه ورد ويزرع
الانجليزي يحب دايما
قاعد على ركبه بيزرع في الجنينه طب انا
خليني خلينا بالمصري الحين المصري والعربي
حاجه حاجات الناس اصبحت اكبر يعني الدوله
في الستينات والسبعينات صار في هناك
حاجات اكبر
تفجروا السكان اعداد السكان فمش مش مش
منطقي انه انه يتم العنايه بشكل كبير
بالخصوصيه بالطريقه التي تتحدث عنها اقصد
الحاجه البشريه الكبيره للسكن ادت الى نوع
من الاسكان سريع ومتشابه ولا يكون في
عنايه كبيره في التفاصيل صح ولا لا لا
مش صح لانه هو
انا في حزبه بس يعني واحد بيتكلم الحاجات
دي لازم تكون في رؤيه
في دراسه عملت على الكمبيوتر
انك انت عامل بالنظام
اللي هو المودرن عمل تاورز ثمان ادوار
وعامل جنبيها منطقه مخططه بالاحواش
المساحه اللي طلعتها بالاحواش
160% من الارض بتاعه التاوس ليه لان
عن بعض عشان الاضاءه عشان التهويه وعشان
كده الحوش لا
فاللي حاصل لو انا قدرت اطلع النفس
المساحه
بتاعت ثمن تدوار في خمس ادوار يعني تقريبا
نسبه
لان الدور انت عارف بيغلى في البناء كل
دول بيزيد 10% كلما ارتفعنا للاعلى فعندك
الخمس ادوار عندك حوش عندك تهويه احسن
وعندك ما فيش ردود
فارتدادات ارتدادات
بلمها في حوش يعني انت لو خدت مثلا
اديك مثل مثلا عشان يبقى قريب 7 × 7 يعني
قول 50 لو انا من السبعه دي
يونت واحده ويونت واحده من كل ناحيه هيفضل
لي خمسه في خمسه خمسه وعشرين
خمسه وعشرين من 49 يعني النص خمسين في
الميه
لو انا بدل ما اخد في الوسط الخمسه اخذت
الاطراف الاطراف كلها هتطلع 24
والخمسه وعشرين هتطر اعمل لها منور عشان
الحمامات وغيره فهي خمسين في الميه اي
بلديه بيقول لك لما تاخد ارض ابني 50%
وخمسه بلكونات فهي نفس المساحه متى بدات
مشاريعك الخاصه بدات يعني تاسيس عملك
الخاص وانطلقت مشاريع اللي عرفوا ان انت
صممت كثير من المساجد في السعوديه يصممت
اول ما صممت اتخرجت صممت ثلاث عمارات في
مصر وكرهت الشغل ليش
يعني
ما فيهاش متعه العماره ما فيها حتى لو ما
فيها لو لو الهندسه بتاعتي عملت يعني
الشغل حلو بالنسبه للي حواليا لكن الشقه
مش مريحه
انا طول حياتي عشت في بيوت فلل وبتاع
وفي انجلترا برضو عايش في فيلا والناس
كتيره عايشه فيلا اللي بيشوي في انجلترا
في الشقق اللي هم العرب اللي بيجوا في
شارع ادلب شهر شهرين وبتاع لكن الانجليزي
ممكن يسكن في فيلا بره لندن لو مش قادر
على يشتري ارض فلندن وبياخد اليوتيوب
المترو يجي لندن ويرجع تاني
الاوتس بتاع متى بدات مشاريعك الخاصه
كمعمال اول ما تخرج اوكي بداتها في مصر ثم
انتقلت للخارج لا بدات في مصر بنيت
ثلاث عمارات
وبعدين جاءت لي فرصه ارض في العجمي اللي
هو منطقه سياحيه في جنب الاسكندريه
كان في واحد قريبنا عنده ارض هناك عملت له
فيلا
وبناتها كلها بتتوب ما استعملتش اسمنت
بدون اسمنتها بالطوب والحجر
[موسيقى]
وابتديت استخدم التكنولوجيا اللي كانت انا
رحت بخاره وسمر كان
وايران وتمنيت انه انا شاب روحتها متاخر
يعني في حياتي لكن اكتشفت التكنولوجيا
بتاعتنا بالنسبه للتوب والحجر
والبنى
بالطريقه اللي بيسموها
اللوت باري
غنيه جدا جدا جدا جدا
وعلم تكنولوجيا يعني قادر على الصمود
سنوات طويله قوي واكتشفت كمان
بالتكنولوجيا الجديده
[موسيقى]
برامج الكمبيوتر لان الحسابات بتبقى صعبه
لكن كمبيوتر بيقدر يحسب يعني حتى السادات
الكبيره دي وبتاع استحاله كانت تطلع بدون
الكمبيوتر لان كان يقعد مثلا المهندس
الانشائي يقعد يحسبها سنتين تلاته دلوقتي
كمبيوتر على طول وبيعملوا
بنايتها بالطوب بالحجر مكتوب لان الحجر
كان موجود هناك
وبعدين التوب عشان اوفر بدل ما يكسروا حجر
كثير تتوب بقى عملت به القبب والابواب
علاقتك مع السعوديه
نجحتيها طلعوا
خان طلع جائزه للعماره في البلاد مسلمين
خدت انا اول جائزه وحطوني على الفرنت كابر
بتاع الكتاب
ورحنا باكستان استلمنا الجائزه كان اول
جائزه اتعملت باكستان
كان اول جائزه للعماره الاسلامي اتعملت في
العالم الاسلامي
فخدت انا اقول جايزه ورحت
ازاء الحق يميها وزع الجايزه
وقعدنا في جاردنز واعملوا حفله وبتاع فدي
سادتني كتير كيف بدات العلاقه مع السعوديه
وتصميم مساجد رئيسيه في السعوديه
رحت بيروت
ان امي كانت عايشه في بيروت
نقلوا من مصر وعاشوا بيروت فرحت في بيروت
عشان
[موسيقى]
يعني اقعد اشوف امي اقعد الصفيه هناك
فخدت الكاميرا بتاعتي وقلت اصور البيوت
اللي لبناني البيت اللبناني القديم ده من
احسن تصميمات اتعملت بالنسبه وفيها توفير
جامد جدا وطريقه البناء بتاعتهم توفير
القشر للمواد
في اقل وابداع لان هو اهم حاجه في العماره
الكلفه انا لما ببني لو حبيت ابني المباني
بتاعتي بالاسمنت المسلح انا انا
بوفر اربعين في الميه من تكلفه وبعدين
بوفر
نص يعني لو محتاج 80 طن الكونديشن استعمل
40 طن
ما احنا في الخليج اليوم عم ندفع مبالغ
مضاعفه على البناء
وحديد وتسليح يعني بعض المهندسين يقول لك
هذه تبني عماره كامله هو كارثه مش انا
بايب على البنى الجديد لكن انا النهارده
ظهر اللي احنا بنقوله من 40 وخمسين سنه
كبتعمل في مصر اخيرا وحضرت هنا اديت
محاضره في كوب ايتين طريقه البناء بتاعتنا
وطريقه المدن بتاعتنا هتجيب الخراب طيب
لان البيئه حطوا علينا ضرايب
هيحطوا علينا ضرايب هرجع لها باشمهندس رحت
بيروت اخذت كاميرتك زرت والدتك وبدات تصور
البيوت اللبنانيه ودخلت في بيت
اسمه بيت المناره
كان في وحده شيخه اسمها شيخه الله يرحمها
وابنها كان انت
مصمم داخلي مصمم داخلي بيعمل بيت
عبد العزيز السليمان في جده اللي هو ابن
عبد الله سليمان اللي كان اول وزير ماليه
ايام الملك عبد العزيز
فهو بيصمم بيت عبد العزيز سليمان وبعدين
قالت لي انت قلت لها بدرس البيوت المهتم
بالعماره العربيه الاسلاميه ابني
[موسيقى]
تعرفك عليه عرفتني على ابنها سامي الخازن
ده كان احسن
بدور على واحد زيك انا عندي زبون في
السعوديه عايز بيته
عربي اسلامي
فتامل
عبد العزيز سليمان ابن الشيخ عبد الله
السوداني
فعملت الانتيرير واشتغلت ورحت حليت مشاكل
كثيره بتاع
فانبسطت مني جدا الشيخ عبد العزيز
جه قال لي اخوه احمد سليمان خليه يبنيلك
بيتك بنيت له البيت طلعت مجله الامريكان
اللي هي بتاعه المعماريه الاميريه
على احسن احسن من بيت تتعمل في جده بيت
عبد العزيز سليمان او اخوه اخوه اخوه احمد
الثاني كان المعماري اتعملت بس الانتيري
والتعديلات هذا بنيته من البدايه
ومن غير تسليح كمان غير تسليح وحيطان
وكانوا يتريقوا عليا
السواق لورائي وده رايه يعني
يخاف من الموضوع انه بدون تسليح
كان البنا بتاعي وهو وابني يقول له يا عم
علاء صعيدي هو يقول لي عم علاء
القبه دي تشيل نجفه
كل يوم يجي يخش يقول له كده يكون معنا ناس
فالناس يقولوله انت مجنون بتبني مدنين
تسليح فهو عشان يبرر نفسه
شايف مهندس عنيد معه
اما لا بص له كده وراح رمل
قال له انت فلقتني بالنجفه بتاعتك دي انا
اشيل لك جاموسه هنا انت عايز ايه طيب كنبه
سليمان مفتاح لعملك الكبير في السعوديه
اخذ جائزه خد جائزه وبعدين خلى امين
المدينه سعيد فارسي شافوا وجابني قال لي
عايزك مستشار ليا
عملت قال عايز تعمل ايه قلت له عايز اعمل
مساجد قال احنا بنديها للمهندسين الخيبانه
مش لاقي شغل انا عايز اديك مشاريع كبيره
قلت له انا عايز قال لي ليه قلت له هو باب
العماره الاسلامي
عملت مسجد قباء فرح مكلمني حسام خاشقجي
كان وكيل وزاره الاوقاف قال له تعالى
عايزك تقابل شخص هنا قابلت حسام خاشقجي ده
حسام حسين خاشقجي وده يمكن اكتر واحد
فادني في حياتي
فلما تعرفت عليه والراجل كان مثقف
ومتالم في المدينه
راجل واخد دراسات
اسلاميه وبتاع فلما شرحت له وكله
خدني وقال لي يلا نبتدي مساكن
وبدت مسجد على الكورنيش كانوا يطلعوا
يعملوا
زكي امانه الله يرحمه
[موسيقى]
بيعمل شاف المسجد ده قال مين اللي عامل
المسجد ده مين عم مسجد ده بتاع المسجد
الصغير اللي عملته على الكورنيش ده كان
اساسا هو بيقول لي عايزك تعمل لي
بمعنى
التجميل المدينه فكانوا يجوا في كل ميدان
يحطوا بسكلته يحط ايد صباع ويتريقوا عليه
يعني جاب الفنانين واحد حاطط هلال
يعني طلب منك تجميل اللي هي فانوس كبير دي
في السيكولوجي وانت دارس سايكولوجي
بيسموها
ده مرض
لانه ما تقدرش تاخد صباع الصباع لو شفت
انت زي الفيلم بتاع القادم ايد بتمشي كده
من غير بني ادم ده تشويه
فقلت له انا
فلسفتي عايز نعمل لك
اعمل لك مسجد في الفن الاسلامي النحت كله
في المسجد من الخط بتاع فدان جزيره وعملت
المسجد شافوه كل الناس على طول بعديها
جابوني وقالوا لي تعالى اشتغل في مسجد
خداع فتح عليا شغل المساجد اللي هو المسجد
عمل في السعوديه عملت يجي عشرين مسكت في
المدينه اكبر مسجد عملته في جده هو مسجد
الملك سعود كبير جدا
فيها عشرين متر قالوا لي مش رفضوا
المهندسين يبنوها
يحسبوها ليه قالوا له
خدت
جازفت وسعيد فارسي قال لي انت لو حاجه
حصلت ما حدش هيطلعك من السجن حتى الملك
فهد لو حد وقع وقف على حد وقلت له انا
واخد المسؤوليه فانبسط مني يعني قال لي
انت يعني بتجاذب بحياتك لمبدا قلت له اه
لان لو ما عملتهاش مش هقدر اثبت عشان متر
بدون حديد
وارتفاع 40 حتى الوزير
الشيخ عبد الواسع جه نفسه وطلع فوق مش
مصدقين على الطاير ماشيه
وبعدين اكبر مسجد في المدينه عملته مقزز
الحليفه
ده خد جائزه المدينه وبيدوها بس للسعوديين
عملوا لي وادوها ليا كمصرك اجنبي يعني مش
من اهل المدينه او اهل السعوديه
وعملت مسجد الحارس وعملت مسجد السليمان
بشكل كبير ليش
العماره الاسلامي
ما اقدرش احييها غير لو خلقت الحرف
ما فيش مهندس يقدر يبني مبنى بدون الحرف
اوعك تصدق ان في مبنى هنا اتعامل من غير
ما جابه مكتب اجنبي ومقاول اجنبي يعملها
ومشاكلها مش قادرين يحلوها كمان انت ما
تستخدم القوالب الثابته تعتمد على الحرفين
تحاول انك انت تبني شيء
تصنعه تصنيع
يعني انت كانك ضربت القواعد لما كنت بعمل
مسجد ابلتين
جبن لادن قال لي احنا نصب
الزخارف
قلت له لو هتعمل كده انا هشيل كل الزخارف
من المسجد هخليه ابيض كده ساده زي المساجد
بتوع
المغرب القديمه
قال لي ليه قلت له لا قوالب ايه
فجبت يجي الف عامل من المغرب وكان لها
صديق عبد الله عيسى كان وزير ثقافه قال لي
عبد الواحد رحت اديت محاضره في المغرب قال
لي عبد الواحد عايزك تساعدني تساعدني قلت
له ايه قال لي المهندسين هنا المغاربه
بعمله الستايل الفرنساوي ومش عارف ايه
والبتاع والموديل
الحرفين عندنا هيموتوا هينكسروا ما في شغل
فجبت الف عامل
وشغلتهم في قبلتين
فلما دخلوا بعد السعوديين دمها عينيهم
لان لقوا الناس دول حيطه بيضاء وجايبين
بيحفروا الخط
والاشكال الهندسيه
مسمار في الحيطه معلقين راديو فاتحين
القران
فكننهم بيسبحوا
كانوا بيهاجموني ليه يعني ما نعمل لما
شافوا
النتيجه النتيجه والروح والناس المغاربه
الحلوين دول اللي كانوا بيشتغلوا طول
النهار بالقران تشتغل ازاي بالقران لو
عندك بتاع
وسكوت في في المسجد الحرف
بتربي الانسان يعني الحرف دايما كل حرفه
بتربي الانسان بس مش مهندس هنا يمكن يجي
في بالي شيء او يجي في باله انه انت
تتعامل مع الموضوع فنيا ذوقيا لكن
روحانيه لكن اذا جينا على الناحيه العمليه
كبزنس كقصاد هذا مش ممكن تبني فيه اشياء
كثيره
مدن تاخذ وقت
كويس طيب ايش ردي في واحد واحد الله يرحمه
مات
كتب كتاب بيهاجم وفي عندي كتاب تاني بيقول
لك
[موسيقى]
ان يعني زي السيارات دلوقتي بتتعمل بالمكن
وكله بيتعمل بالمكن وفي مهندسين يقول لك
دلوقتي هنجيب برنتر يعمل بيت
وبتاع فهو الراجل ده قال حاجه مهمه جدا
اللي هي ان
الكرافت الحرف هترجع ها
عند عن
المشينز المكنه المكنه ليه قال كده
لان المشينس هتاخد الشغل من العمال كلهم
فعشان يعيشوا هيضطروا يرجعوا لشغل اليدوي
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لكم انتم مشاهدينا
الكرام على طيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء
الله في الحلقه القادمه دمتم بخير وفي
امان الله